thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here Essences with us in
Tulsa myosins how are you hi what's up
I am I just talked to you um so I me and
my husband are trying to restart well we
never actually officially started like
trying to start you know with the baby
sick the hardest part is getting like
the thousand dollars and you know the
disc no Mahal whatever and I have an
hardest time trying to figure it out
because I feel like our debt is so use
our expenses are so much and our income
is not matching that so I need some help
on what to do kind of how to start and
you know system some words because you
know we're upside down our cards I just
feel bad but it's not worth much anymore
belief so oh so what's your income we
make my husband make like 17 an hour and
I make 20 an hour are you getting 40
hours yeah she got good income coming in
yes I think it's just so much bit in the
expense this is the biggest part and you
don't have budget well we know no you
don't have a budget
that's what we downsize you just don't I
know you don't yours you're making
enough money
what is your how much your car payments
oh it's 400 a month and then a shark is
163 for it's just one car payment and we
on our other car that's good okay and
how much is your rent it's like 900 a
month okay and um what other debt do you
have um bit my husband has like 20 in
student loans and I have like 90 and
student loans
medical bills credit cards how much deal
how much do you owe on the medical bills
oh I found medical leave I just I've had
like 25 bucks a month on know much do
you owe on the medical bills um I would
say probably like maybe 5,000 maybe okay
which means you don't know
okay no not exactly and how much do you
owe on credit cards we owe about
eighteen hundred okay
all right here's what's going on right
after doing this for 30 years you guys
are not organized and here's what I want
you to pretend I want you to pretend
that I was going to hire you and pay you
two hundred thousand dollars to
straighten out these people's finances
and these people's finances is you
pretend like you just got the best job
you've ever gotten in your life that
somebody was going to pay you two
hundred thousand dollars however if you
do not straighten out their finances
you're going to get fired now what would
you do you'd get real stinking serious
and real stinking detailed immediately
and there wouldn't be any I don't know
you'd know exactly what your medical
bills are you'd know exactly what your
credit cards are you would lay out a
detailed in-depth budget every month and
you and your husband would lash yourself
to a tree until you got this done you
would tie you know duct tape around your
ankles to keep you out of a restaurant
and you would get this mess straightened
out that's what's got to happen here you
guys have been playing with this and I'm
not fussing at you I'm just observing
I'm just observing and I want you to win
and you called me because you want to
win but what's going to have to happen
is you got to get serious so serious
that you're not doing anything else
you're like obsessing about like I was
paying you $200,000 a year you got a new
job making 200 grand a year you're
getting paid twenty thousand dollars a
month to straighten these people's
finances out that's your job and these
people happen to be just like you and
your husband and you're going to get
fired if you don't get there late if you
don't get them straightened out that's
how you treat it and you're like oh my
god I got a guy get okay I'm not gonna
think I don't lose our job I'm gonna get
so serious it's gonna be unbelievable
and we're not thinking about nothing
else and we're gonna babysit these
people we're not gonna let them make any
dumb decisions and we're going to put
them on a detail budget then we're going
to lay out that debt snowball in detail
you have an
of coming in to get this done now you
may have to put some of the that huge
student loan on hardship deferral if
you're if you're paying on it at all if
you're not paying on it then it's not
really draining you right now and you
quickly get that thousand dollars in
place and then you begin to whittle down
and beat on the debt snowball and yeah
you may pick up extra jobs or extra
hours you may you may try to get that
car sold as you said you've already
tried to do that you're upside-down
you've got to work through those things
there's a lot of work for you all to do
but to be able to get under control and
save that first thousand dollars is
going to require a lot more
intentionality around the details in the
organization of the debt snowball ever
obsess on the details and the budget go
to every dollar calm and get that laid
out
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you